the sick just keep on comin there's no
letter but the epicenter of this
outbreak every corner is crowned with
patients and it's moved at a frightening
pace in just a matter of weeks the virus
which originated in Wuhan has spread to
every region of China the infections
have now utterly eclipsed the number of
SARS cases during a year-long outbreak
and it's still spreading across a range
of countries the doctors at ground zero
and those dealing with victims around
the world are coping with an
international crisis crying out for
international action as government's
scrambled to get their nationals out of
the epicenter this was a plane carrying
Americans from Wuhan it became apparent
different countries had different
strategies to deal with those returning
home
the Americans will not have an enforced
quarantine period whilst others will a
plane organized by the EU set off from
Portugal to pick up a range of European
nationalities it's unclear what will
happen to those they pick up but the
crew saw the flight is a mercy mission
it's a humanitarian mission and we are
proud to bring the people back it could
be any of our families you know stranded
there so it's important that this
European people come back as that plane
left hundreds of stranded Britons were
being told they'll be flown out now on
Friday ending days of confusion and
concern they face a fortnight in
quarantine on return the worldwide alarm
meant an Italian cruise ship was kept in
dock at a port north of Rome it's six
thousand passengers all locked down
after a Chinese couple on board reported
feverish symptoms they finally tested
negative for coronavirus
in Hong Kong there on the front line of
this health crisis the medics are
urgently trying to contain it but they
have more border crossings with mainland
China than anywhere else and they fear a
spike in cases is just around the corner
the hong kong medical facilities are
already under pressure and the next two
weeks are going to be critical because
of the virus's 14-day incubation period
an estimated 200 to 300,000 people are
due back in hong kong from mainland
china after the new year lunar
celebrations but this virus can hide
itself this is a city's first corona
virus patient and he didn't have a fever
when he first went to hospital he was
only admitted two days later when he
returned still unwell and still with no
fever
this time on the x-ray we found a patch
of pneumonia in the middle of the island
so as a reason he was actually isolated
the doctor who first treated him as both
health adviser to the world body and to
Hong Kong's chief executive he
forewarned of a global emergency and a
lot of it is because this is a new
deadly virus what there are a lot of
unknowns about this new rymus how is it
transmitted now we can only assume this
is through respiratory droplets and
contact with the droplets but the source
of animal we have no idea what it is
okay so if you don't know the source it
makes it difficult and so far there is
no autopsy performed for those who have
deceased so we don't have a little we
don't have much understanding about the
pathogenesis how many organs are
involved medical staff the world over of
bracing themselves the next few weeks
will be decisive in learning just how
far the virus has spread and how severe
it is Alex cords
Sky News Hong Kong